So the iron law of performance can easily
be applied when we spend a constant number of
cycles for each instruction. But how about unequal
instruction execution times? Meaning we spend different numbers of
cycles for different instructions. So this is our
original item law of performance. The number of instructions
per program, times the number of cycles per instruction,
times the clock cycle time. If we have different
clock cycles per instruction, this part becomes a sum
for all types of instructions. The instruction count of that
type that we have to execute times the cycles per
instruction for that type of instruction. Note that, in the
original iron log performance, this was really how many
cycles we need to execute the program. This is how
many cycles we need for each type of instructions. All
of them in a program, and the sum here is
simply summing up over all types of instructions.
So this is still the number of cycles we
execute in a program. And we still have the
clock cycle time here. So the new CPU time
here is like this. So if we have
different CPI, meaning different cycles per instruction for different
types of instructions, then we need to do this,
and just multiply that with the clock cycle time.